[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
well it's hump day
welcome to wednesday
happy
hump day
we made it here
of course there's
all kinds of big news today
oh such surprising news
russian
russian television
announces
that
donald trump is their partner
putin's partner donald trump
of course we knew this
from footage
when donald trump asked
uh putin again in russia again to find
hillary clinton's emails no maybe what
no it's uh now it's hunter binding's
laptop
uh russia if you're listening
there's a laptop and it's got three
million dollars in it
or something like that maybe
maybe they earned three million bucks
or or the laptop paid someone three
million bucks maybe that's what it is
maybe maybe the laptop is the one
holding the sex orgies in washington dc
with all that russian mayor money or i
don't know what the [ __ ] he's talking
about
grandpa's sprinkles
slid off his donut
it's absolutely ridiculous
that this
we are seriously in a timeline
where people listen to that [ __ ]
dribble
from that bonehead
on on traitor tv or whatever the hell it
is i can't figure out if it's like a
patriot news network or a christian news
network or just straight up
straight up trader tv
real america's voice or some [ __ ]
it's it's got a real bad stench to it
like just the view well we're gonna
we're gonna
we're gonna play some of it here because
you know we don't look away here on the
tony michaels podcast
we do not look away we have to see these
things
oh boy so we gotta go through that also
kyle rittenhouse kyle rittenhouse
got ghosted by the president of the
united states
what the [ __ ] what what in god's name
would give kyle rittenhouse the idea
that the president of the united states
would call
and congratulate him on
murdering two people and getting away
with it what the [ __ ] is he talking
about
and [ __ ] idiot
so we're gonna go through that today too
we're gonna watch we're gonna watch
giuliani's fart pillow jenna ellis
interview
kyle the murderer rittenhouse that's
right you're a killer you're a murderer
and you're a white supremacist that's
what you are you're not one of god's
children kyle you [ __ ]
so we're gonna go through that today so
that should be fun oh by the way i
invited kyle on the show officially i
don't know if you guys seen that on the
twitter account i tweeted at him i said
hey man come on the [ __ ] show let's
do this come on the show
we'll chat it out if you want to chat
with somebody
if you really want to chat with somebody
somebody real
who will get real with you kyle
come on this show buddy won't last two
[ __ ] seconds
but anyways we'll we'll see what turns
out he ain't gonna come on the show he's
he he can't he's whining about the
president ghosting him he won't come on
this show good morning everyone good
morning mj's here says hey [ __ ] van
robin is here good morning robin
all the midas mighty is here midas
uh margie is here
ken is here patty here kathy here
midas ken is here
of course you know we we broadcast every
single weekday
monday
through friday karen says she's already
in love with it love it already thanks
karen over on facebook
we broadcast every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
youtube twitter twitch
on all three of those channels and now
now we're on midas touch facebook
facebook page so we're over on the books
of face
we're not only on the tubes of you
and the twitch thing whatever that is
we're also on the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends and now we are on the
the facebook the books of face should we
go i don't know can we do this can we
get on myspace i don't know if we can or
not
i don't know if that's a thing i never
animize based maybe we can try it
i'm just
i'm just messing around having a fun
time this morning
yeah
there's a lot of good stuff going on in
the world and we're distracted by
cocaine orgies
um that apparently
no republican wants anyone to talk about
what the [ __ ]
number one who
who in the [ __ ] thinks that a bunch of
old wrinkly ass men are having cocaine
fueled sex georgie's number one number
two who in the [ __ ] would invite madison
cawthorne anywhere anywhere really i
mean anywhere i i wouldn't even go
[ __ ] out to eat with that son of a
[ __ ] i wouldn't look the old saying is
if you eat if you go to dinner with 10
nazis
and you're sitting at a table having
dinner with 10 nazis you're a nazi i
would not have dinner with madison
cawthorn i wouldn't do it
i i would interview him you damn right
we'd bring him on the show i'd eat his
lunch but i wouldn't eat lunch with him
for [ __ ] sure [ __ ] that guy
and [ __ ] fascist he's a bonehead too
such an idiot what why did he think it
was a good idea to talk about cocaine
sex orgies i don't know anyways we got
sex orgies um putin's uh partner trump
uh you know you really shouldn't say
things like that
russia that you're partnered with trump
that putin's partnered with trump we're
passing laws here in florida to not say
things like that you cannot say things
like that in our country god damn it
things like okay you can't you can't gay
you can't say you can't say gay
so we're going to talk about rhonda
santa signing the don't say gay bill a
piece of [ __ ] now we got a few more
people coming in nancy's here nancy says
hello
deanna's here regina is here jay is here
debbie from salt lake
good morning good morning robert uh from
facebook is here brian from facebook
david's here thomas is here crystal from
facebook is here holy moly we have so
many new listeners
and why we have while i have the
microphone with all the new listeners i
do i do want to say i want to tell you i
really do appreciate
you guys coming every single weekday
noon eastern 11 central live on youtube
facebook now uh twitch twitter
it's been such a fun fun thing every
single day and it's gonna get even more
fun because we're gonna have more people
participating if you guys wanna get in
on the youtube chat because we do have
super chat now over on youtube
um you can do that where you can do a
super sticker you guys will see that in
the shows to come as you keep watching
and keep listening
uh so subscribe to the youtube page that
way you guys can find and click the bell
notification and comment down below and
like and subscribe whatever the hell i'm
supposed to say
i'm not good at this youtuber stuff
but if you're on facebook or anywhere
just go ahead and like
like share retweet whatever the hell
where whatever platform you're on do all
that stuff
but we really appreciate you joining us
um as we break down the tweety tweets
and attorney trends the news the
commentary of the day in the way that i
like to do it the tony michaels way i
guess you'd say
where we rant and rave and we talk about
the things that are important
and we drag the things that are not so
goddamn important like
i don't know
hunter biden's laptop
uh uh donald trump losing his [ __ ]
mind
can't put he can't string words together
or ideas even
how he's partnered with russia as russia
is uh still
trying to take over a sovereign country
of ukraine and just putin's trying to
destroy democracy around the world
trump's like oh yeah i'm gonna
i like this guy this guy's cool he's
he's trying to get rid of democracy
folks if you haven't [ __ ] figured
this out yet that putin's enemy is
democracy
trump's enemy
is democracy
you see a pattern here do you see why
these guys are [ __ ] holding hands
you see why the russian
government is posting on their state tv
that they're that they want to partner
with trump they want to oust biden as if
that's a thing russia can just snap its
fingers
biden's out trumps in like they're the
[ __ ] coach or something get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ]
anyone out there that has a trump
sticker a trump flag still hanging you
know tattered on their [ __ ] front
porch
they should walk out there this morning
and take that [ __ ] down
it is now i mean you don't need i mean i
don't know how much more evidence these
[ __ ] boneheads are going to need
but it is now more obvious than ever
that trump is not it's not just
colluding with russia he is an enemy of
democracy
an enemy
of
democracy
with the news that we see this week
the enemy of democracy and his delusion
is becoming more and more dangerous as
we take along every day
just like putin's delusion
that he can just take ukraine without
consequence
that that's the way that's the way he
remains in power
is dangerous
to ukrainians
so
what what else what else are the trendy
trends oh yes susan collins susan
collins is in the trends because you
know
she is susan collins
so we'll talk about susan collins and
kbj judge brown jackson today and the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends we
also i think gabe's going to be joining
us um here in a little bit we're going
to be talking about we have a game going
on you guys have really been enjoying
the game
bonehead madness we've been playing a
game over on the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends so make sure you follow us
at tony michael's pod to play bonehead
madness
go over there and follow us
there will be some more games today
between the boneheads yesterday were
some great matchups
great matchup yesterday uh so we'll
we'll look at who won and bonehead
madness in the bracket system of the
game you guys know we play bonehead of
the week we put up a poll
every single week on the facebook page
all right excuse me geez on the twitter
page i'm getting too many social media
places where we're trending i'm getting
all confused turned around
we put the bonehead of the week poll
where you vote
you get to vote for the bonehead of the
week at tonymichaelspod
on twitter
the podcast
twitter account page the poll is there
you get to go over there you get to vote
who you want to be bone of the week and
then every single friday
we go through in the second hour of the
show that's right we're on two hours
every single weekday in the second hour
of the show on friday we go through
bonehead of the week we go through your
vote what how you guys voted for bone
into the week and we add a few extra
boneheads in there this week is going to
be extra special because we're not only
going to do the bonehead of the week
poll we're going to do bonehead madness
we're gonna do both
now it's gonna be a
tight here and there but what we'll do
is we'll go through bonehead of the week
like we normally do and then we'll go
through
uh the winners you know like the the
final four i think i think he's calling
it the uh the uh
what's he calling it the deplorable four
i think that's what he's calling it the
deplorable four and then of course the
championship and then we'll go through
the champion maybe maybe by then the
actual bonehead
uh madness champion
will be the bone end of the week too i
mean there's a possibility don't rule
that out don't rule that out that can
happen in this world that we live in
this timeline that we have right now
so come play bonehead madness at
tonymichaelspod on twitter follow us
while you're there
this is gonna be a fantastic fantastic
rest of the week we're getting over the
hump of the week
and there's been a lot of news i i don't
know if we're gonna see
we we saw the contempt charges move
forward through the committee the select
committee
um
for peter navarro and dan scavino
yesterday we're going to go through this
matt gats hunter biden laptop moment i'm
going to [ __ ] drag that [ __ ]
today so stay tuned for that
um
where he tries to introduce what he says
is the contents the contents of hunter
biden's laptop
mr chairman
i have in my hand
the contents of hunter biden's laptop
that way fox news can play this clip
over and over and over again
what a [ __ ] idiot
so we'll go through that moment as well
this is going to be a fantastic week
folks fantastic week the economy is
booming biden's booming
and trump is busted let's go through the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back to the [ __ ] list roundup
where we round up all the tweety tweets
in the journey trends yes we have
reached that part of the show
of the show of the tony michaels podcast
thanks for joining us here
on youtube twitter and twitch and now
the mind is touch facebook page for all
you new listeners out there this is the
part of the show where we go through the
tweety tweets and the train trains
that's right we surf twitter live on air
it's kind of weird i got the idea a
while back
these these youngins these yous
remember the
the uh the movie my cousin vinnie raise
the use
use yeah they use
you know the youngins
the kids
i got this idea from my son he would he
would watch
people play video games
while he was playing video games
and i was like well why do you do that
he's like i don't know it's fun so i
thought you know what i might do i might
i might surf twitter
and you guys can watch me serve twitter
while you're surfing twitter so it's
kind of fun and it's turned into a whole
thing here with the [ __ ] list roundup
but let's go through the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends let's start on the
on the timeline
um you get notice you see this you see
this here i want to show you guys this
see that little button that says promote
i did something yesterday twitter has
been bugging me to like turn on the
you know the professional thing i didn't
know even what the hell the difference
was well here's the difference
i can now pay to boost my tweets
how stupid is that
who i mean i guess if you're a company
or something you got like a product
why would i why would i promote this
tweet
it says here let me make it bigger so
you can [ __ ] see it
partner trump is trending so i wrote i
wrote putin's part
partner trump question mark careful they
passed laws against this stuff in
florida
and that was the first thought i had
when i seen this uh it's probably not
the you know it's probably not the
safest tweet
uh you know some people might be
offended by it but it's true they're
trying to pass laws where you can't you
can't say gay and you can't allude to
that two people who are the same of the
same gender
are together you can't do that anymore
in florida that you might hurt a
conservative's feelings
you might hurt somebody's feelings down
in florida
if if if someone knew that a child had
two mommies you just might hurt their
goddamn feelings
oh my god it'd be the end of the world
if someone knew that a child had two
mommies or two daddies oh my god and it
has to do with sexuality let me ask you
something because i i i posted and we're
gonna watch this video of ron perlman
absolutely [ __ ] destroying ron
desantis
the [ __ ] destroys him i wish i could
put out a video that destroyed someone
as good as ron perlman but he does such
a fantastic job
i mean he absolutely crushes him
let me ask you this question because i
reposted that video i was like oh my god
this is such a good video i went and
shared it on tiktok because ron just put
it up on twitter i'm like oh this gotta
be over tickets so i put it over on tick
tock and everyone's you know
reposting this video and i said ron
perlman destroys ron desantis
in the in on the video
and then the comments were
you haven't even read the bill it
doesn't it's not the don't say gay bill
that's not what they call that's what
democrats called it if you ever even
read the bill why would you want to
sexualize a kindergartner that's not
that's not what it says at all
you
people who wrote the bill are
sexualizing kindergarteners
you're you think because
because a kindergartner
has two mommies that that's a sexual
thing
two people of the same gender loving
each other doesn't have to be sexual you
[ __ ] weirdos
why in the [ __ ] can't we as democrat now
here's what they're really mad about
they're really pissed off that they
don't say gay
that that that messaging that
that worked and democrats did a really
good [ __ ] job at messaging that we
should do that all over the place we
should take that operation that happened
down in florida even though he still
passed the bill because they're [ __ ]
bigots but everyone in the country knows
their [ __ ] bigots now
and it's tied to the entire republican
party because that's what they want they
want to ostracize and outcast anyone in
society that is the other that's what
they want that's what fascists do
and they have become full-on q anon
fascist
but this is the number one [ __ ]
argument this was the number one
argument
in the comments section is well you
sexualize and kindergarten it's not sex
you
are sexualizing kindergarteners in the
bill you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
no one no one no school anywhere
is is giving sexual education to
kindergartners in florida
you're the ones who make
who make homosexuality a sexual thing
just because you love someone of the
same gender doesn't mean it's a sexual
thing you [ __ ] weirdos
people just because a man and a white
man a white christian man and a white
christian woman boy they can be together
they can love each other and that has
nothing to do with sex
they really can't put that together but
they can't put together that two people
can love each other i mean yeah married
people generally have sex but that's not
what it [ __ ] has to do with you dumb
[ __ ]
you are the ones who were obsessed with
other people's genders
you are the one who are obsessed with
other people's genitalia in bathrooms
you are obsessed with it
absolutely [ __ ] can't handle
yourselves
so much so that you hate bicycles and
electric cars and you think gay men go
in girls bathrooms what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
marjorie taylor hoof foot green you
i better not say it out loud i've been
getting in trouble for saying the c word
people and not really
because i've been
i've been aiming the c word at certain
people people like well i don't like
that word but
when you say it to that person it's the
truth so how am i gonna how am i gonna
rebut that
but here's the thing
this is the same [ __ ] stupid-ass
[ __ ] that they pull when they ask
when
marsha blackburn
that [ __ ] [ __ ] i'll say it for her
when she asked kbj judge brown jackson
when she asked her what's a woman
and of course you know
judge brown jackson did the whole back
and forth why can't
why
can't someone say well that a woman is a
gender that's what it is a woman like
you you want to know the argument when
someone asks you this let me tell you
let me give you a little lesson on what
you say
when some dumb [ __ ] thinks
they're gonna they're gonna school you
on on who what's a man and a woman and
why it's so stupid that you think this
or you think that you live toward let me
tell you something when someone asks you
what a man is or what a woman is you say
it's gender
it's a gender go look the [ __ ]
definition up it's a [ __ ] gender
whoa what what wha what constitutes
blah
that's all you got to say that's it
when they ask you
what is a woman you say it's a gender
that a person
identifies as
that's that's what it is it's a gender
that a person identifies as
some people
feel like some people are born
of that certain gender and they remain
that gender their entire life some
people are born of a different gender
and identify as that gender
what the [ __ ] do you care what do you
care how someone identifies they s they
care so much about what the definition
what the definition of [ __ ] gen what
a woman is
they care so much
about that definition
and they're so focused on that word but
you can't say gay don't say gay don't
say gay that might offend that might
offend some people some people might get
scared
they might think they're gay
oh what if they're gay and they don't
know they're gay oh my god that would be
horrible
to all those out there that are still
[ __ ] on the fence about this don't
say gay bill
the intent
is is to ostracize
gay children and gay parents
out of the schools and out of society
out of the community that's what it's
designed to do to make sure that they
know
through the law through the legislature
and through the power of the fascist
governor of florida
ron desantis
that we have power and we have control
over you
that's the goal
that's the goal just like the
confederate statues didn't go up
didn't go up after the war
they only went up when the when the ku
klux klan wanted to make sure
to let black people know in the south
that hey you might think you're free
but you're not
free
that's what the bill is designed to do
don't believe me go look at the
anti-trans bills in texas
look at the
anti-anti-woman bills in texas missouri
louisiana all over the [ __ ] country
we still have power over you
that's what they're saying
we can take away
your
liberty
that's what they're saying
it's not it is nothing it has nothing
to do
with sexuality
nothing
what what does gay have to do with sex
anyways
these people have absolutely lost their
[ __ ] minds
that they think because a man loves a
man or a woman loves a woman or a trans
man loves a man or a trans woman loves a
woman
or whatever
whatever it doesn't [ __ ] matter it's
none of your business
but that that if you love someone if you
have a connection with someone that it
must be sexual
it must be because in their minds
and their minds
a white cisgendered male
who has a rapist
misogynistic mentality
the only way you love someone
is if they're a sexual object
that's why
that's why
right there
ron desantis sees his wife as a sex
object
got it
that's that's how he looks at her so
he must believe
he must believe
that a gay man loving another man sees
him as a sex object
think about it
that's why
it's why they're doing this nonsense
that's why they can't say gay
so when someone out there asks you what
a man is or what this is a really stupid
[ __ ] question by the way
wha what is a man what is a woman
like they like like marsha blackburn
ask askitanji brown jackson and they're
all over the book you can't even they're
in the comments everywhere you've seen
them
on twitter facebook
tick tock they're in the comments
everywhere what's a woman you can't even
tell me what a woman is here's your
response here's your [ __ ] here you want
to know write it down hell i'll [ __ ]
post this [ __ ] on twitter so you got it
it's a it's a gender that a person
identifies as
that it's that simple it's it's a gender
that a person identifies as see what
they want what what
what republicans want us to say what the
answer what their answer is is a woman
is a sex object that has no liberty in
this country
nor should she have any power should she
have the right to vote
nor should she have a [ __ ] opinion
and if she does have an opinion she can
get her barefooted ass back in the
kitchen
that's what they want us that's their
definition
of a woman
so when they ask you that that's what
they want you to say
just say you say when they ask you so
all you gotta say when they say what's a
woman you say it's it's it's a gender
that a person identifies as
watch them watch them lose their [ __ ]
minds
there you go there's there's my tip for
the day all right let's get back to the
the timeline be careful out there about
putin calling trump putin's partner
because uh there are laws in florida
against that type of stuff because we
have fascists in this country um
woodland points out here charlie kirk is
on a seven-day twitter suspension this
is his final warning
in other words if he [ __ ] up again
he's gone for good apparently that's
what hoodlums saying here
he took himself hostage after being
forced into a gop orgy uh he does kind
of look like he's in a hostage situation
here or
he just finished up
with an orgy with a bunch of uh
60 70 year old
republican congressman i don't know
it's uh that's what madison cawthorne
says that
there's a lot of 67 year old republican
congressmen that love to have orgies
cocaine fueled orgies and that
well speaking of dumb [ __ ]
here's another really good great this is
a great video everyone on here hates ted
cruz who doesn't hate ted cruz
like al franken said i like ted cruz
better than most of my colleagues and i
hate ted cruz that's what al franken
says
listen what what's what ted cruz ted
cruz
thinks he's
kyle rittenhouse
gets on um jenna ellis's uh show
rudy giuliani's fart pillow julie uh i
excuse jenna ellis
ted cruz gets gets a little jelly here
bad jelly so he's gotta go on eric
bowland's show whatever [ __ ] network
this is on
whatever fascist
network this is on trader tv
um and he asked he has to one up
what up kyle rittenhouse he can't be out
written housed here listen you know the
question you just asked eric i actually
get to ask that almost every day
somebody says who's really you know when
when he says that i get them asked that
question although he's never been asked
this question
he's never been asked this question
before because he's been in cancun the
whole time he doesn't talk to his
constituents why would he take questions
from his constituents that's kind of
gross his constituents down in texas are
icky
running things and let me tell you the
scary thing
i have no idea so biden's been president
what 15 months yeah in that entire time
i have not spoken with him once who in
the [ __ ] who why number one why the [ __ ]
would president biden talk to this [ __ ]
anyways number one number two who in the
[ __ ] i said show me one person who wants
to talk to take crew who would even want
to talk to [ __ ] ted cruz in the first
place
give me a [ __ ] break ted no one wants
to talk to you
no one wants to talk to ted cruz nobody
absolutely [ __ ] nobody show me one
show me one even his dog doesn't want to
talk to that [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
uh kyle broke some news yesterday um we
heard this
yesterday the justice department is
seeking 131
more attorneys to pursue more january 6
related pros uh prosecutions um this is
because they have such a big massive
pile
of prosecutions i think they're over 800
now um and it's growing
as and and the the we're working our way
up the ladder too um so they're seeking
more attorneys to to sift through um the
especially these lower charges where
they're trying to get these people
through court with plea deals um they're
trying to get because some of these
[ __ ] idiots are gonna they're
sovereign citizen type morons
you know they think that they relinquish
their [ __ ]
they wrinkle relinquish their
citizenship and they're not citizens of
the country so they can't held
accountable the laws or whatever i don't
know
i don't know
i have no idea
so the the the department of justice is
seeking more attorneys uh mayo
oh says has anyone else noticed that all
the shittiest people are trending today
and that that that was yesterday and
there was a lot of shitty people
trending yesterday uh mass and gotham
being one of them uh thank you for your
your tweet there
mayo did i did i give credit to kyle uh
tell the people listening we give credit
here
we give credit if we read it we give
credit so if you're out there and you
see a credit on your on your tweet that
means we read it on the show
um and it says here's what it says
it says thanks for the tweet featured on
the [ __ ] list roundup
and then it's got our twitch handle
because we do have a twitch channel so
you go over there and listen to it live
as well
but that that's that's what it says so
if you get that little receipt
from me that means we read your tweet
live on the air
okay and and then we got another one
about your your
your tweet sucks because sometimes we
got to read a tweet that we don't really
want to read
but we got to have a tag for it to make
sure we know we read it so it's your
tweet sucks your tweet [ __ ] sucks
okay
uh
captain [ __ ] here uh
patriot takes post uh a clip from real
america's voice
you're gonna buy some this [ __ ] guy
all right let's
okay
i know a lot of people and i'm probably
gonna lose a lot of people here by
playing this moron's voice but listen
this is this i you cannot look away at
this you cannot look away and this is
why you must not look away is because
the a lot of people out there that you
still know that would vote for this
[ __ ] fool won't see this
they won't see this they don't know it
exists they have no idea that this
bonehead doesn't know what bread is or
how to buy bread
i'm dead serious this is what this clip
shows if you haven't seen this yet this
[ __ ] has not no clue what a
grocery store is no clue
no idea and the the only store that
could come to his mind is tiffany's
and then he lives in the 1960s where
there's the hardware store down the
street
i don't know it's really [ __ ] weird
it's really [ __ ] weird let's let's
listen to this garbage an example supply
chain
you go to a store they don't have bread
we're like a third
you go to a store you don't have is is
anyone going without bread out there
i mean i'm not always the one that goes
grocery shopping i and and to be frank
it's very rare that i'm actually the one
that goes and does the the essential
grocery shopping you know milk bread
eggs that sort of thing
they've never been out of breath what
the [ __ ] is he talking about there's
like
there's like a thousand choices of bread
i don't even know that we should have
that many choices of bread really
frankly it's really kind of stupid this
is the reason why we think we we this is
the reason why people in this country
get freedom confused they think well i
have the freedom to have a thousand
choices of bread that's a freedom that
is awarded to me no i mean that's called
[ __ ] capitalism they're trying to
trick you into thinking that one load is
different than the other and you're
going to pay a different price that's
capitalism that has nothing to do with
freedom that's their freedom to take
your money dumbass
it ain't your freedom to choose between
15 different types of frozen pizza
you're a [ __ ] bonehead it's my
freedom to get a whopper from burger
king no it's not that's not a freedom
that's not an entitlement you dumb [ __ ]
but this is this pla he plays into this
stupidity but this guy's never been in a
goddamn grocery store in his life you
know i know
yeah i know because he thinks the bread
the bread shelves are empty when is this
when is this fat [ __ ]
went two [ __ ] hours without having a
piece of bread in his hand
surround a piece of bread surrounding a
[ __ ] cheeseburger or a hot dog
get the [ __ ] out of here look at this
guy
there's no way this guy's ever went out
with went without bread
you go to a store they don't have bread
you get that [ __ ] we're like a third
world country they don't have things you
go to buy something at tiffany you go to
buy you go to buy something at tiffany
who in the i mean i'm sure there's some
listeners out there mine who go to
tiffany i'm sure
i've never been inside of tiffany i
don't even know that i can recall that i
walk past one i'm sure i have but what
i'm saying is i don't recall because i
wouldn't go into tiffany probably more
than likely
and i don't know that a lot of my
listeners would go into tiffany
what the [ __ ] is he that's the first
store that he picked out
he should have said walmart
think about it he should have said hey
listen think about who he's talking to
he should have said walmart
or even even just [ __ ] up and said
like kmart or something right
i don't know
the piggly wiggly
i i can't figure out why this guy said
oh i know why he said tiffany because
that's the only [ __ ] store that come
up in his [ __ ] mind when he was
thinking oh yeah well the last time i
went shopping i went and do it tiffany i
guess and then and then listen to what
he says at this he says you go to to buy
something after buy something at a
hardware store a hardware store you mean
lowe's or home depot or menards
they there is no hardware store any more
of the big box stores put them all out
of business
there's a very few hardware stores out
there and you don't refer to them as
hardware stores
is this the 1960s what a bonehead he
probably he's probably like hw bush he
doesn't even know you [ __ ] there's
barcodes in these scanned you remember
that you remember that back in back in
back in the early 90s
when george h.w bush ran against bill
clinton george h.w bush goes into a
grocery store
and he's checking out grow he's helping
the checker check out groceries and it's
like you know they're trying to have a
photo op right like george h w bush
george h.w bush is a normal dude so he's
checking out groceries and he as he's
scanning the barcodes he's fascinating
he's like oh my god this technology is
so fantastic oh my god it's like i live
on an alien planet or something
the four years i've been president i i
can't even believe the
the modern technology that has happened
and they're like dude this shit's been
around for like 12 years
that's what this [ __ ] is like
there's no bread in a grocery store get
the [ __ ] out of here hi
hello they don't have product
they say even me when i order things
like for furnishings for a building or
something when i order things like
furnishings for building or something
see he doesn't even order the [ __ ] for
his buildings and it's obvious when he
says it like that
they say it's going to take nine months
to get it
no no no it's gonna take you nine months
to pay for it dumb [ __ ] that's why they
don't just give it to you
they're not gonna give you credit
anymore grandpa poopy pants they they
know who you are now they've read the
[ __ ] articles in the new york times
about how you don't pay your [ __ ]
bills
so they're gonna demand cash up front
and yeah it might take you nine months
to get the cash to pay for the
[ __ ] to siphon it off your your
[ __ ] cult
but yeah they're gonna demand cash up
front dumb [ __ ] this to be like same-day
service
same-day service supply chain
this is this is the best part he says
supply chain he just says that i don't
know supply chain
now listen to this i thought when i when
i first heard this this is important
when i first heard this when he said
supply chain and then he said we've
never heard that term before i thought
he was gonna take credit for inventing
it i really i really did i really
thought like in my mind when he said it
he was gonna be like
i invented the term supply chain no one
had ever turned heard of a supply chain
until i became president i'm the one who
created supply chains in the american
economy
oh [ __ ] this this [ __ ] [ __ ] how in
the [ __ ] do these people listen to this
dumb [ __ ] and realize he doesn't
know what the [ __ ] he's talking about
there's no bread get out of here with
that [ __ ]
supply chain
we never even heard the term nope never
wasn't like
no the system was working the system's
totally broken our system is broken
uh-huh tell us why going into socialism
oh and going into communism oh socialism
and communism all at the same time that
just proves you people don't know what
socialism and communism is you have no
clue
social economists are not the same thing
not even close and you and you [ __ ]
say it's two things at the same time
that are totally different people are
[ __ ] dumb you're stupid you're sheep
it's a cult
and it's obvious and guys i i know i
know this it feels
like because the hashtag arrest trump
now
is trending the reason why he's doing
this [ __ ] because we're gonna show a
more important moment in this interview
i want to show this moment so you guys
can go out there and show your trump
family or talk to your trump family
about how this guy's a [ __ ] bonehead
because he could have pounced on gas
prices right he could have done that he
could have pounced on gas prices because
there's a big huge and the media is
having a [ __ ] heyday today about how
the economy is booming and joe biden's
numbers are slipping it's all [ __ ]
we're gonna go through that too that's
all [ __ ]
but
he could have pounced on gas prices
which is the easy one that was the easy
one but he said something that's not
true for anyone
especially his voters his voters in
white america in white grocery stores
there's bread a lot of it
got it
in white rural areas in this country in
those grocery stores there's bread and
there's a lot of it
he's full of [ __ ] [ __ ] and they
should know it and that's how you do
this um but the other thing too about
the supply chain
i do i do want to ask someone who's a
trump supporter
how doesn't a world famous the most
brilliant business person in the entire
world how hasn't he ever heard
of of the terms supply chains get the
[ __ ] out of here you are such a [ __ ]
joke
you you are i can't even [ __ ] believe
after this little clip i said grandpa's
sprinkles have slid off his donut i
can't even [ __ ] believe
after this clip that this guy
[ __ ] was in charge of anything for
four years of our country
it is absolutely [ __ ] gross it's
scary
that we got to the point to where that
it was even a [ __ ] possibility
what a [ __ ] mess we we were in and
our end
that
these people would vote for this
[ __ ] again
so that's what we have to do you have to
show them how stupid this idiot is
and this is a prime example
this is a prime example of showing
people who you know who are [ __ ]
still trump supporters and i know it
feels like oh well tony our obligation
to try to change their minds
i don't know what else we're gonna do
i don't know what else we're gonna do
we're gonna have to get them
we're gonna have to wake them up slap
them up and throw cold water on them to
get to pay attention somehow
uh
joe says i prefer presidents who ignore
ted cruz
i prefer anyone
anyone who publicly
uh
ignores ted cruz that's one person i
tell you i would let a lot of people on
my podcast hell i i invited kyle
rittenhouse i would not let ted cruz on
this show [ __ ] that guy i would not let
him on the show uh gabe found this
and maybe if gabe joins us here soon
we're 47 minutes into the first hour if
gabe joins us soon
he says can we arrest trump already um
this is a statement the 29th it says the
radical left democrats in congress and
the unselect committee are spreading
lies about me again
why are the democrats spying on my
presidential calls
i already told jeff bezos
washington post that i have no idea what
a burner phone is i've never used one
and never heard of them
and anyone like john bolton who says
i do is lying
with a capital l which is weird so
instead of spying on my phones they
should be looking into crooked hunter
biden's
laptop matt getz tried to expose him
today
but noodly nadler
is covering it up we can't let them get
away with the crime of the century
now i'm not gonna say this is real i'm
not gonna say it's fake either but you
you [ __ ] figure it out i don't know
gabe released it
you know gabe sneaks into mar-a-lago and
um
pisses off daniel dale by releasing
statements every once in a while so
uh daniel if you're listening i don't i
cannot confirm or deny
if this is real um
okay
let's work down here to the jenna ellis
clip
giuliani's fart pillow jenna ellis
on the jenna ella show
she had the murderer kyle rittenhouse
the killer the murderer the white
supremacist
the woman beater that's right you're all
those things you [ __ ] we got evidence
okay let's this just got 1.1 million
views goddamn
and goddamn let's listen to crybaby kyle
talk about how he got ghosted by the
president united states or you know is
is calling you out on twitter uh what
would you like them to know most about
your story
um yeah i was attacked i was seventeen
not a racist not a white sword yeah you
are
you weren't you weren't you were you
murdered two people
you're a killer you went there with a
gun not to be a medic just because you
had nice little gloves on doesn't mean
you were a medic
medics don't normally who go to protest
who go to peaceful protest normally
don't carry
assault rifles to make sure to kill
people that's not what they do
you little [ __ ] but listen to why how he
how he ends it the premise is i'm not a
domestic terrorist i'm not a murderer
yeah you are and anybody who wants to
sit down and have a conversation i'm
more than open i read hey kyle hey kyle
i would love to sit down and chat it out
you little [ __ ]
let's do it come on the show man
i'm trumpeting out there i would have
you on my show
two three days a week if you wanted you
wouldn't last five [ __ ] seconds come
on kyle let's go let's chat it out buddy
i'll have you on the show
let's do it hell i'd pay to go to a
studio
to sit belly to belly with you buddy
that's right
i'd interview you live and in person
buddy
so if you want to talk if you want to
talk you want to chat about how you're
not a domestic terrorist how you're not
a white supremacist how you're not a
[ __ ] killer
let's do it
let's do it man if you want to chat
since you're so sad that the president
united states won't take your phone
calls the [ __ ] out of here reached out
to joe biden several times crickets
nothing he still hasn't replied so
you see his little smile like he thinks
it's like joe biden doesn't have time to
[ __ ] with you
like what makes you think just because
you went to a peaceful pro a peaceful
black lives matter protest
and and and you killed two people
at a peaceful protest what makes you
think that's
a cue for him to talk to you on the
phone
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
this shows how much of a man he is to
not sit down
talk to a 19 year old oh
oh how much of a man he is huh kyle
well since we're talking about how
[ __ ] manly you are mr 19 year old
man up
come have a chat we'll chat this [ __ ] up
yeah i'll chat with you i'll interview
you i'll ask you the really [ __ ]
tough questions that the fascists that
you're running around the country going
on their shows won't ask you because
they're fanboys of you because they love
that you went and killed protesters they
love that oh they love they love when a
white supremacist goes and kills a bunch
of protesters especially at a black
lives matter protest you [ __ ] ain't
right they love that they loved him some
of that
so come on the show buddy i'll ask you
some [ __ ] questions
we'll chat it out
be a man
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
you little sniveling little
little turd
come on the show kyle it's an official
announcement i'm not [ __ ] around i'm
not just saying it you can come on the
show buddy
come on the show let's do it
let's chat it out
he's sad he's gonna cry the jew biden
joe biden ghosted me we were supposed to
be friends
i really thought that he was gonna pay
attention when i threatened to sue him
even though i have no grounds to sue him
get the [ __ ] out of here
uh don lewis points out something very
extraordinary
better extremely inexplicably late than
never lynching becomes a federal hate
crime in 2022 this is a real [ __ ]
thing
they just the president united states
just signed a bill in 2022 making
lynching a hate crime
in a federal in a federal jurisdiction
just now 2022.
so we are doing things democrats are
delivering because let's be frank
there were three [ __ ] republicans
that are pro lynching
uh thomas massey you remember the guy
with the [ __ ] the christmas card
where his whole family posed in front of
the uh the christmas tree
with their assault weapons they were so
christmassy wasn't it
and then the christmas spirit bang bang
pew
pew
bang bang bang pew pew pew bang bang
bang bang
i don't know
i don't know i'm just trying to figure
out how [ __ ] assault rifles have to
do with jesus in the manger and [ __ ] and
jingle bells
and chestnuts roasting over the open
fire i don't know that's the guy the guy
with the christmas guard
thomas massey he was one he he's pro
lynching
not only he's pro-lynching he doesn't
want it to be a hate crime he definitely
wants you to be able to lynch
black folks in the south without it
being hate crime that [ __ ]
um
speaking of the [ __ ]
madison cawthorne um
pointed out that
republicans love to have cocaine field
orgies which we kind of went over this
yesterday with gabe i don't know i don't
know how much i believe this [ __ ] he's
just making [ __ ] up for a podcast maybe
they are having cocaine-filled orgies
but can you imagine can you imagine
going to a cocaine field orgy with ted
cruz
or our [ __ ] tom cotton get the [ __ ]
out of here
with a bunch of weirdos like that come
on man matt gatch you really want to
show up
and have to venmo that guy a entry fee
to the orgy get out of here
you don't want that [ __ ] on your venmo
record
hell someone might someone might suggest
you enter it into a record of official
record of congress
the contents of matt gats venmo i think
gabe's the one who uh tweeted that so
okay i'll give him credit but i said if
i had a coke field orgy i damn sure
wouldn't invite republicans
i mean i wouldn't invite republicans if
i was gonna have a coke field orgy
that's for damn sure that's the last
people on earth i'd invite
is is is [ __ ] republicans oh god
how much of a buzz kill would they be uh
here's what gabe said about the written
house uh interview he says kyle
rittenhouse is upset uh with biden for
high gas prices not calling him back and
spilling his milk
kyle i am really serious i am dead
ass serious man
if you hear this you guys you need to
clip this out go post it i'm still i'm
going to keep tagging him and tweeting
him
i am dead ass serious man
you can come on the [ __ ] show
buddy and prove that you're a man
uh i i tweeted about the the gqp orgies
i said it wasn't an insurrection it was
a gqp orgy is that what is that what is
that what the sec get the sex
this the sex events
that the coke fueled orgies are like an
insurrection
if it lasts more than four hours and i
don't know i just
oh boy oh boy oh boy let's see what else
do we have here on the timeline
um
we've got
i think i had the video oh here we go
here we go
here we go
here is the uh ron pearlman yesterday
here's what happened yesterday when me
and gabe were on them
we were we were searching through doing
the tweety tweets and training turns
there at the very end of the show there
was a couple things i still wanted to
get to and we had like five minutes left
you should go listen to yesterday's
episode it's fantastic by the way you
can re-watch it on youtube twitter
twitch you can also re-watch it on my
facebook page but more importantly you
can download it on apple the most the
most boycotted platform spotify and all
your other directories wherever you
download your podcast you can go listen
to it there so go listen yesterday but
at the very end ron pearlman was
trending and i wanted so badly to click
into it
when we were on the show it was right
there you can even see me like moving up
and down if you go watch it on youtube
at the very end like i'm moving up and
down deciding do i want to click on ron
perlman do i want to i don't say it but
you know i'm obviously
you know moving the screen around trying
to not click on ron perlman
and the reason why is because i knew
ron had probably made a video
because he made a video about ted cruz i
don't know was it last week or was it
like yesterday i don't know
he made him he made me he made a video
about ted cruz a couple days ago and
it's [ __ ] hilarious you gotta go
watch that one
um
but this one and i and i seen him
trending so i was like oh god he's he
hadn't made another video about someone
maybe it's ted cruz and i thought no i
can't click into it because if i click
into it it's going to take 5-10 minutes
for me to go through the video
of ron perlman absolutely destroying
somebody
and i was very sad after i after the
fact because i went after the show and i
went and and seen why ron pearlman was
trending and i was correct it was a
video that he destroys someone and he
destroys ron desantis
and
the fascist leader of florida right the
the fear her of florida
now that's what he thinks he is like
ron desantis thinks he's the fear of
florida like he thinks he's the almighty
leader or some [ __ ] he's the dictator of
of the country of florida i don't know
he's a [ __ ] idiot
but ronnier
really puts him in this place let's
listen to what ron says about ronnie ron
says about ronnie
good morning governor desantis
from here
um
don't say gay
don't say
as the first two words
in a sentence spoken by a political
leader of a state
in the united states of america don't
say
don't [ __ ] say you [ __ ] nazi pig
say
first amendment
read about it
then run for office
you piece of [ __ ]
i could not say it any better than the
way ron perlman said it right there oh
my god
uh ron ron deserves an oscar um and
maybe maybe even uh ron desantis could
present the oscar
and ron perlman could uh you know maybe
hearken back on them
uh and
a historical event in the i'm just
saying i'm just saying i'm just saying i
want to you know
want to promote
deanna says here um
he's a dictator all right
deanna i think he's a limp dictator ron
desantis that is he's a limp dictator
probably
thank you ron perlman for your
contribution to humanity i posted this
over on um twitch
like i said earlier
and everyone everyone said you need to
go read the bill it doesn't it's not
called it's not called don't say gay
that's not what it's called that's what
the democrats called it
like that was some of the first comments
right like that's what that's what they
were saying
and that's like that's like the most
important part here
it's like the actual really important
part
is that democrats did a really [ __ ]
good job
of making that bill the don't say gay
bill
i mean that's literally what it does it
makes it to where
people
can't admit
to
their
orientation
whether they're gay or not like a little
child in kindergarten has two mommies
can't say yep you can't say that you
can't allude to the fact
now now
uh a child in kindergarten who has a
white mommy and a white christian daddy
oh you can you can say that their
parents
are bone all the time oh yeah their
parents are humping like [ __ ]
like stone test bunnies
because they're hetero right yeah that's
that's not that's not against the bible
that's not i mean even though it doesn't
it there
there is gay in the bible and jesus
didn't say anything against gays
but we don't like them
but you can you can talk about how
johnny's mommy and daddy hump all day
long
but little sally she's got two mommies
you just cannot you have to avoid that
conversation it might offend some people
it certainly does that
it certainly does that
and yeah the republicans didn't call it
don't say gay but guys we all know it is
that you know why because there was good
messaging around that [ __ ] bill
good
messaging
even ron perlman in this video is
accusing ron desantis of calling it the
don't say gay bill think about that
messaging
this [ __ ] video look at this let me
pull it up here
let me show you
why this is significant in messaging i
talk about it all the time on here
this has 3.1 million views
3.1
[Music]
million views that's fantastic
that's fantastic
and the messaging in the video is is ron
desantis called it the don't say gay
bill
which everyone's like well that's not
the truth who gives a [ __ ]
we have to be intolerant of intolerance
okay that's what we have to do as
pro-democracy people in this country we
have to be intolerant of intolerance we
have to stop [ __ ] beating around the
bush we have to stop [ __ ] placating
to these [ __ ] bigots we have to stop
com capitulating to to the [ __ ]
fascists because we don't want to hurt
their [ __ ] feelings [ __ ] that offend
a fascist and offend them now
yesterday all day
early
we have
to take
our democracy in control
they want to have the reins of power to
take away your liberty and to take away
our democracy that is ours they want a
fascist state
and they keep saying the quiet part out
loud
so we cannot tolerate intolerance we
can't we shouldn't and if we do
we are in big big trouble
that's why we can't look away at this
stuff the [ __ ] cheeto dust mobster
talking about how there's no bread in
stores and we're like oh you're just
giving him a platform get the [ __ ] out
of here he's donald trump what are you
talking about that i'm giving him a
platform
you must see this because people who are
voting for him people who would love him
who got their bumper stickers and their
tattered flags on their [ __ ] trucks
that are [ __ ] causing gas prices to
soar even higher because they're wasting
gas in convoys with their [ __ ] three
three mile a gallon pickup trucks that
they don't haul anything in
besides a trump flag
and a confederate flag
listen
we these people don't know that trump's
saying that there's no bread anywhere
when these people are buying more bread
and eating more bread than they can
[ __ ] manage
this [ __ ] bone-headed idea that we're
communists and socialists now
when the oil companies are [ __ ]
gouging us
private profit companies are [ __ ]
gouging us and we're in socialism and
communism god damn it
number one you don't know what socialism
communism is and you're not aware of how
crude and oil crude oil prices and gas
prices work
but we cannot be tolerant of the
intolerant and we have to have our
messaging straight in florida the don't
say gay bill
as much as it wasn't officially the
don't say gay bill we made it that way
folks we made it that way
that's the most important part and we
can do this
all over the country in every district
across the land in our nation's capital
in state capitals in [ __ ] school
board meetings and in city councils
county councils we can do it everywhere
the messaging
and we can do it with the [ __ ] truth
because the truth is as much as they
want to say well it's not called the
don't say gay bill that's
what it is
that's what it is
that's what it is that's the truth
so the messaging was perfect we just
need to cut copy paste
got it let's do that
everywhere thank you ron again
thank you thank you
for your video
please
please do not stop
and please give us
give us more videos i'm here is speaking
of videos of
speaking of videos that we need to watch
here is one of matt gatz
in in a committee hearing
with the fbi
um
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take a quick break after this break we
will be right back
and i will drag
matt gatz and maybe
maybe we'll read an official statement
from hunter biden's laptop oh jesus
we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the
live love and blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em [ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome
welcome back to the show
[Music]
mj
thank you for the super chat
she says ron perlman
is the hero of the week
it's a damn good video you should share
it everywhere and keep sharing it and
keep sharing keep sharing thank you mj
for the super dad as you guys know we
are live every single weekday as we're
at the top of the hour here
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central monday through friday two hours
we go live
some call it a radio show
some call it a podcast
some call it a youtube channel some call
it a twitch stream
or a live stream there's all kinds of
names for it
all kinds of names for it but what you
have to know is two hours a day every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific we
have the microphone on
and we go through the tweety tweets and
attorney trends sometimes we have great
interviews uh we we interviewed bad brad
berkwitt last week you guys gotta go
watch this interview with bad brad we
show the video of alvin berkwith his dad
and speaking because we just got off
from the break of talking about ron
desantis
and the don't say gay build
and in 1977 uh anita bryant went down to
miami to uh help
help discriminate against gay people
there was
a bill they were trying to pass to make
it to where
workplaces could discriminate against
gay people
of hiring them they could they could
fire him for being gay and that's that's
what anita bryant was pushing for and
there was a group of people
and advocates for gay rights and human
rights as it were
in the 1977
not not
2007 not 97 80
1977 in miami
and there was there was human rights
advocates gay rights advocates that went
down to miami and they were passing out
shopping bags to make people realize
that if they take away rights
from a person who is gay they can take
them away from you too
once they take your liberty away and
they do that with a legis piece of
legislation they can start taking
someone else's and start taking someone
else's and someone else's someone else's
and the fascist will eventually come
after you
and it's a great interview
with brad because we play that clip
it's it's it's an nbc news archive clip
it's about a minute or so long
and it's a fantastic clip of alvin
berkwith and this is where brad gets his
activism but that clip is so powerful
and and the thing that shines through
that clip i wish i had it here i'd play
it
maybe i can i can come up with it here
since we were talking about it
now let me see if i can find it here
while we're talking
uh the thing about that clip
is that it's so powerful and so true
even today
just today
with this don't say gay
bill the anti-trans bills that they're
trying to pass
to try to snuff out other people's
liberty
it's real it's here let me see if i
could find it
um that's is that the one no
hang on a second hang on a second
103
no yeah it is oh that's it oh yeah i
think i found it
i found it here
here it is
um i'm trying i'm trying to obtain the
entire clip
in a digital form
that way we can show you guys
but this
this clip is fantastic
um
it shows
alvin
um
berkwit here
and he's again he's in miami
he is passing out shopping bags
in support of human and gay rights
where anita bryant and if you don't know
this go look it up
she was a crazy ass christian who was
running around trying to take away
people's rights because she didn't think
they had them
human rights didn't think they adam
and she was hiding behind her religious
dogma to justify her bigotry just like
amy coney barrett
just like ron desantis just like greg
abbott
just like the the [ __ ] legislators in
missouri and idaho and mississippi
the gqp in general
marjorie taylor green stands on stage
and talks about bicycles and bathrooms
and that gay men go in little girls
bathrooms number one there's no little
girls bathrooms there's the women's and
the men's and then a family bathroom
it's all [ __ ] racist bigoted
homophobic tropes
continually continuing and you don't
you don't doubt me it they won't stop at
women
they won't stop at women you they're
uteruses they won't stop
at gay people they won't stop at trans
people they won't stop
they won't stop at black people they
won't stop at muslims
they won't stop at jews they will not
stop
listen to alvin berkowitz and take a
lesson here allow one just one human
being to be allowed to have his rights
taken away from him as a human being
than pal you don't have any right when
they got to take away your rights
because if you say screw you to them
they say screw you to you and six
million more jews line up in the toilets
and i'm not going to wind up with them
beautiful beautiful clip there
again that is that is the uh
that is the
the shorter version of it that i have
found online
um that i cut out
but there is a longer version if you
want to watch the full longer version go
go watch let's see that was um
let's see what episode was it
it was episode 103 but we posted the
interview alone on the youtube channel
so go over if you're there now you can
subscribe or go over to the youtube
channel and subscribe to the youtube
channel just search
the tony michael's podcast or tony
michael's podcast you'll find it
and watch the bad brad berkwitt
interview
where it shows the full clip
of alvin berkelet
um
being a activist for human rights
because that's what we have to do
that's what we have to do
um
in our country right now is protect
human rights
that's what we have to do
okay let's let's move on to this clip
here
um this
dead oh god i can't even believe we have
to do this this is going to be trending
again
uh hunter biden's laptop is going to be
turning in hunter bind's laptop is going
to have to release a statement
now because
matt gatz has interjected it into an
official uh congressional hearing listen
it is not
it is not illegal to own a laptop it is
not illegal to um
email someone from a laptop
[Laughter]
it really is not
but let's watch
let's watch the the sex trafficker
accused sex graphic trafficker excuse me
soon to be indicted sex track traffic
sex trafficker
matt
gets
a florida by the way if you guys are new
to the show i do call him matt getz
not gates it's not spelled gates
and i'm not gonna say it like that i say
matt
gets
and the reason why i do that mainly
is because i hope that the son of a
[ __ ] comes and watch
watches something just just just even
just a just a clip
and i'm saying his name matt gatz i
figured that would piss him off so [ __ ]
you matt getz
here's him
blabbering on about a laptop tell you
what mr chairman i seek unanimous
consent to enter into the record of this
committee
the contents of hunter biden's laptop
i can't is that is that a hard drive is
that what that is like an external hard
drive is that what he's got in his hand
i don't know
i don't know what i don't know what he
the contents
of hunter biden's laptop number one
okay here's the thing if they thought
that there were so many [ __ ] crimes
committed on if hunter biden's laptop
committed so many [ __ ] crimes right
if they actually thought that they would
not
they would not submit it into evidence
or unto the public record of a committee
hearing got it
they would go and [ __ ] give a
referral to the fbi
here's what no one is saying about the
laptop
this is what because
rather hunter biden's laptop has [ __ ] on
it or not who cares if he owned a laptop
it is not [ __ ] illegal to own a
laptop
matt gatz i bet owns a laptop
i bet the fbi would be very [ __ ]
interested in the contents
of matt gatt's laptop
i would guess that they might even have
the contents of matt gatt's laptop
i or or someone
who has part of the contents
of matt gatt's laptop maybe joel
greenberg i don't know
listen
no one who is trying to see criminal
charges against hunter biden's laptop
because really it's become its own
figure like hunter biden isn't even a
thing anymore it's just the laptop the
laptop is the thing that they're [ __ ]
obsessed with
if you wanted
criminal charges to be pressed against
hunter biden's laptop right
if that's what your goal was here you
wouldn't submit it as public evidence in
the committee hearing you dumb [ __ ]
you would give it as a referral to the
fbi because anyone can give a referral
to the fbi let's say let's say you work
at a place right
and you me i don't know you sit down at
someone's computer and you notice that
they have stuff on their computer that
is highly illegal
you can actually call the fbi
you you don't have to be a congress
person you don't have to be a law
enforcement officer you don't have to be
a principal you don't you have to be a
boss or someone in charge you can just
make a phone call to the the either the
local
the state or the federal uh law
enforcement agency and you can say hey
there's some crazy [ __ ] on this [ __ ]
computer i'm looking at i don't know
who's i know who's it is
there's some crazy illegal [ __ ] on here
and they'll take that referral just like
if matt gas really had the contents of
hunter biden's laptop which he doesn't
he does not have it if giuliani had it
he does not have it he would have been
giving a criminal referral
give me a [ __ ] break
this is all this little clip right here
is for fox news and fox news alone
because
jerry nadler here the committee chair
he's not the best chairman in the world
i i'm not saying i don't like jerry
nadler i just don't like how he's a
committee i don't like how he chairs
committees
he's kind of a bonehead
because listen to what jerry nadler
already responds here this is the clip
they're looking for this is the part
they're looking for the [ __ ] internet
trolls the q and honors
which i'm in possession of
i'm not
what jerry nadler should have said here
is no denied request denied
and then moved on
to val demings val dimmings has the
floor request denied you do not request
no unanimous consent
there's no objection to that
yes there should have been immediately
objection
denied request denied moving on to val
demings that's what he should have said
[ __ ] [ __ ] matt gets and [ __ ] [ __ ]
whatever he's got on that hard drive
whatever it is probably blank
do you think he even uploaded anything
to the hard drive object
pending further uh investigation what's
the basis of that objection see that's
what they wanted that's what they wanted
right there and then if you go to the
end of the clip of course they move past
this
um
he's trying to submit a receipt
from a repair shop
hunter biden took his laptop to repair
shop because it was broken oh my god
breaking news chairman this is just
am i next
oh i'm sorry mr chairman i seek names
consent to enter into the record the
receipt from the department chairman
this is
and val dimmings in true style and
someone who actually should probably be
the chair the chairwoman of the
committee val deming should probably be
the chair of this committee at this
point when you see what happens here and
she just steps all over matt gats steps
all over the chair and says look i'm
going to take control of this committee
without objection and now miss demings
um
thank you so much
mr chairman and and
that's how it's done
that's how it's done
jerry nadler and mad gats do
these [ __ ] rubes
okay
let's let's go to the let's now let's go
we're
22 23 minutes into the second hour and
we're going to the tweety tweets and
trendy trends finally um oh bruce willis
bruce willis is stepping away from his
acting career
mr trump are there
it's a shame that some of your [ __ ]
the people you love the most in the 90s
in the movies are such [ __ ] boxes now
you don't think bruce willis is [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him
kind of wish
maybe he was presenting the uh the award
uh the documentary award
when will smith did what he did i'm just
saying okay booming
is trending number six booming because
the press is
out of their minds
um
msnbc says
president biden's approval reason has
fallen to the lowest level as his
presidency despite booming economy
according to nbc news polls this really
does show that the media is way out of
whack
they're still in the trump loop right
they're still in the [ __ ] trump loop
here
what i mean by that is they got it they
got to do the whole president bad thing
right
they can't they can't get out of this
loop that president must be bad
if it's the president must be bad
they're in this
they want
they want the trump ratings back is what
they want
right
so they're trying to make
they're trying to make biden trump or
some [ __ ] i don't know what the [ __ ]
they're trying to do here number one who
gives a flying [ __ ] about biden's
ratings
do you know why do you know why do you
know who's not gonna be on the ballot in
in in the midterm
do you know one name for sure that's not
gonna appear on any [ __ ] ballot
not one [ __ ] ballot
you know who it is type it in the chat
if you know who it is not what one
[ __ ] ballot is gonna have this guy's
name on it
in november
not one
the only way that he's even associated
with people on the ballot is because we
let that be the messaging
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
we can change that [ __ ] that's right
everyone says biden here
listen joe biden's approval rating
missed one says trump yeah that that's
another name that's not gonna be on the
ballot but that's the thing
that's the thing with messaging we need
to put trump's name on the ballot
we need to put trump's name on the
ballot
he doesn't do well he doesn't do well
and especially after the summer that
we're going to have
with all the january 6 convictions
and and trials that we are going to have
and more plea deals and more conspiracy
charges
that's going to be important but biden's
name is not going to appear on any
ballot
msnbc knows this they know that the
polls don't mean [ __ ]
they know that they know that they just
want they just want this fancy headline
that biden's approval rating is in the
[ __ ] even though the economy is great
what's going on biden must be bad
president
that's the [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] here
and i'm gonna i'm gonna give him a
little your tweet sucks msnbc you see
that
your tweet sucks featured on today's
shitless roundup congratulations msnbc
your tweet [ __ ] sucks now here watch
watch what happens when i push reply
twitter asked me do you really want to
tweet this
tony do you really want to tweet this
do you want to tell msnbc
that they suck
you goddamn right i do tweet that [ __ ]
okay
let's move on down the list here um
here's here's here's fred fred says
don't take the bait the only reason
um
the only reason why trump and sycovants
are pushing hunter biden's crap
is to distract from coming news about
trump's children
rather dealing with drug use or other
criminal activity it is coming keep
focused on ukraine booming economy and
success of the present united states i
agree with fred to an extent but i you
know
look this whole they're gonna eat their
lunch on this hunter biden laptop stuff
they're gonna eat their lunch
don't don't get it twisted they're gonna
eat their lunch on this
hunter biden laptop [ __ ] just like
they're eating their lunch on the
insurrection
just like they're eating your lunch on
the insurrection oh karen
karen i always tweet
i always tweet when i want to tell
someone their tweet sucks
never stops me never stops me
karen says tweet it tony i think i tweet
too much sometimes uh maybe sometimes i
don't tweet enough okay
uh let's see what else do we have in the
biden booming category
what else do we got of course um some
people are pointing out that that that
the
economy isn't so much booming for some
people
that inflation is up well the problem is
folks
listen the problem is with the inflation
is democrats fixed that they had a fix
for that they had a fix for that last
year
this is one reason why our economy is
booming so hard
because last year they passed coveted
relief which gave inflation protection
listen to me
it gave inflation protection it put in
bank accounts every single month money
directly into people's bank accounts
in the form of a child tax credit that
was inflation protection
and they could still do that
they have a bill it's called the bill
back better bill which is the problem
with it the messaging
right
the democrats successfully
branded a bill in florida don't say gay
because that's what it is they
unsuccessfully branded an education and
inflation protection bill
in washington as the billback better
bill
they they're really horrible at that
but there's inflation protection inside
that bill and honestly i think i think
democrats should start doing this
in the summer they should start breaking
off uh parts of the big bird bill i call
it the big bird bill they should they
should peel off the education parts
uh where school children start school at
three instead of five and that's how
they should stay say it do not say
universal anywhere in your [ __ ] words
get that word out your [ __ ] mouth
they they peel off the education part
and they say school children start
school at three instead of five
that's what they say
and and put all the goodies in there all
the good stuff
don't don't
don't just do that just say that's all
you're doing right just say that's all
you're doing and then here's what they
should do is call it inflation
protection they should have an inflation
protection act is which they should have
and it should be in the form of a tax
credit
to everyone in the country that goes
directly in your bank account we know
you can do it government we
we know you can do that now we are aware
that you can put money directly into our
bank accounts
we have evidence of it
and we know you can do it so the
democrats just should just have a bill
that's the inflation protection act and
they shouldn't just give it as a child
tax credit they should give it to as a
tax credit to everybody
everybody now they could have means
testing you know rather you have
children or maybe you're retiring you're
on social security i mean there's
there's all these things that the
government knows about us that they
could do means testing on it on the
amount that a person would receive but
everyone should receive inflation
protection
everybody call it biting the biden
inflation checks
there you go
there's you some messaging right there
democrats are you listening
oh these boneheads that's one reason why
the economy is boone because we did
inflation protection for a whole year
the other thing that's booming the
economy that's going to cause the
economy to boom
is the uh the art of inflation
any anyone realize that anyone realize
why the economy and why uh
rich companies like oil companies are
making so much [ __ ] money right now
is because inflation
and that means gouging
that's what it means
profiteering
off of this idea of inflation right
so in that inflation protection bill
maybe maybe they should have some
uh anti-trust trust busting laws you
bust it up [ __ ]
like the oil companies go after those
son of a [ __ ]
give some money to federal dollars to go
after oil companies and stop gouging our
asses maybe you should do that
gouging commodity companies from stop
gouging us too all that bread that isn't
on the shelf get the [ __ ] out of here
but that [ __ ]
that's all you have to do
that's all you have to do is word it
correctly
what what trump pump an idiot do you
know
is gonna not take a [ __ ] uh a gas
price inflation check every month
well goddamn you mean the government's
going to give me 500 bucks so i can fill
up my my my ridiculously big truck with
ridiculously big tires that gets three
miles to the gallon with an eight foot
bed that i hauled nothing in i mean
besides my trump flag my confederate
flag of course that is
of course they're gonna take that of
course they are
of course they will
and and
and on the other hand if you give them
inflation protection and
you tell the [ __ ] oil companies you
cannot [ __ ] gouge anymore you can't
gouge anymore
if you do that
you will fix a lot of things democrats i
don't know i i
what are they gonna listen to me
they aren't gonna listen to me they'll
listen to you though yell and scream as
loud as you can over and over and over
again everywhere you can not just on
social media
i'm talking about it city council state
meetings legislators get them [ __ ]
get them
go out there and tell them we want
inflation protection we want you to bust
up the [ __ ] oil companies trust bust
now stop them gouging us
joe biden doesn't have a gasoline button
on his desk it's not he can't he's not
he doesn't control the price of gas at
your pump you dumb [ __ ]
but the politicians in the legislator
state federal otherwise they do have
control
they got control they could put money
directly into your bank account american
people they did it before they can do it
again
that's right go after him okay let's
let's go back this just booming stuff is
ridiculous
oh biden's numbers are tanking while the
economy's booming
the economy isn't booming for everybody
it's booming for all the big fat cats
who are making all kinds of money
gouging us so do something about it okay
now hunter biden is trending course we
already went through that we already
went through the hunter biting [ __ ] and
all that dead
but and and it's probably it's probably
has to do with some of the [ __ ] tax
the tax [ __ ]
and then um also
the other thing is this [ __ ] video of
uh the cheeto dust mobster talking about
how he wants russia to find [ __ ]
for uh
on the buddins uh susan collins
she's in the news
breaking news
senator susan collins of maine
think someone has learned their lesson
oh wait no that's not the headline plans
to convert to confirm
judge katanji brown jackson to the
supreme court the first republican the
backer listen
we knew senator collins and murkowski
were going to vote yes on katanji brown
jackson and when manchin when joe
manchin says yes i'm going to vote for
kentangi brown jackson we knew judge
brown jackson is going to be a supreme
court justice there was no there was no
[ __ ] question about it
there was no question about it that's
what happens
it was all art and theater
for republicans
that's all it was
was art and theater for republicans to
do their little q and on tap dance
inside of a senate judiciary committee
that's right it's a q and on tap dancer
trying to appeal to the base the the
tail is wagging the dog as it were okay
uh today what else do we have we're 36
minutes into the hour
oh let's make this a little bigger so
you can see now waiting to see i want
you to be able to see see
see it see there oh
it's bigger you can see it now okay
uh let's go to the for you because
partner trump was trending earlier
trader trump is trending now
which i'm not opposed to that hashtag uh
old all day every day here it is
partner trump was trending i read you my
tweet
but let's re read the reason why partner
trump is trending a russian state
television host said the country should
encourage a change of regime in the us
yeah we do that every four years you
dumb [ __ ]
like every four years we encourage a
change we have an election
you can choose to keep the same
[ __ ] or you can choose to pile 8
million votes against that fascist fat
[ __ ] like we did the last time
and again help russia's partner trump to
become president
here's the thing here's the most
beautiful part about this story
vladimir putin heard
joe biden say
that guy does not need to be in power
and he got pissed he got pissed he was
pissed at joe biden
joe biden
he was so mad at joe biden
that he made uh his host on russian tv
uh
say that we need to have regime change
in the us which
we don't have regimes we have
administrations and every four years the
american people are encouraged to make a
change
like we did the last time
we did that the last time eight more
eight million more of us were like we do
not want that fascist french fried [ __ ]
in office anymore [ __ ] that
[ __ ] the cheeto dust mobster
[ __ ] grab all poopy pants send them down
to mar-a-lago
we did that we changed the regime
russia putin
partner with trump to become president
oh they're not colluding they're not
best buddies get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] what does daniel goldman
say daniel goldman says russia calls for
its partner trump to be installed as
president trump calls for russia to help
him politically
all the while russia commits war crimes
through a brutal unprovoked invasion of
another democratic nation
this is the leader of the republican
party
hello
hello think mcfly
think you got a fascist on your hands
republicans
you might want to pay attention
to what putin and your dear leader are
saying to each other
now let's see what oh rick wilson always
always with the layup here rick wilson
says our partner trump is a phrase that
will live in infamy
i think i think rent rick's hinting at
something here i think he's saying
lincoln project is not gonna forget
that russian state tv vladimir putin the
murderous dictator
use the phrase our partner trump
oh my god they said it out loud they
can't stop
they can't stop themselves they can't
they can't quit
they can't quit it they love
the pooty poot
vlady daddy i can't stop
uh let's see kate kate one of our
favorite here says
if you still support a twice in peach
corrupt former president who is now
being referred to as our partner trump
quote unquote by russian state tv which
is controlled by the bloodthirsty
dictator
i just don't [ __ ] know what to say to
you
like
yeah [ __ ]
people lost your goddamn fascist minds
and that's really the the revelation
here right
is that these people are allowed um to
have you're allowed to have all these
these these uh warm feelings for
vladimir putin the murderous dictator
you're allowed to really be a fascist in
this country now you have the freedom of
idea and the freedom of thought and the
freedom of speech
you do not you do not get to impose
your speech on others that's not speech
anymore when you impose your speech on
others like past laws to oppress the
rights of other people that's not
liberty and you're not allowed to do
that in this country
but you can have you can harbor your
thoughts you can you can have your
bigotry you're allowed to do that
it's the freedom but here's the thing
here's the thing
is that
you're saying it out loud and we all
know who you are like before
we kind of thought that there was a big
you know part of the country that were a
bunch of [ __ ]
weirdos who you know were concerned
about other people's genitalian
bathrooms they were really [ __ ]
worried about who loves who and who
doesn't love who they were really
[ __ ] really concerned about women and
what they do with their uterus super
concerned for a long time they've been
concerned but we didn't we weren't aware
that it was all like this
thin veil for fascism they called it
conservatism it's not conservatism but
they always unveiled it as that and it's
fascism it's outright fascism
and they love authority fascists love
authoritarians they love them and it's
no more clear now than ever when they
love putin and they love putin's partner
trump
okay
let's uh i gave kate credit right i gave
credit yep i gave credit there yeah if
you read it we give credit
okay what other uh aaron
um says here late last night russian
state tv said the quiet part out loud
they want to re re-elect their partner
trump and that and aaron makes a really
good point here
because you know they're they're saying
you know they're pounding their chest
saying we're gonna replace
russia wants to replace biden tear down
the regime
and then put in trump and stall trump
but here's what they're really saying is
they're going to help him
if you're unaware any trump supporting
candidate or any candidate that trump is
supporting
in 2022 in the midterms here you want
some messaging you want to tie these
[ __ ] up to something
in 2022
if they are if trump is backing them and
they're backing trump
they're pro-putin
they're pro-russia
they're anti-ukraine they're
anti-democracy they don't want democracy
democracy's their enemy just remember
that
and russia is helping them in an attempt
to do that
russia putin is helping republicans
trying to run midterm elections here in
this country
because they're partnered with trump
to become the leader and look in 2022
that's all that's all matt gatz marjorie
taylor greene joe walsh who is running
in washington's third at nazi
they want to make donald trump speaker
of the house mancat said it at the last
[ __ ] nazi rally i mean trump rally
excuse me the last nazi rally they had
it in georgia
he wants to make donald trump's speaker
of the house that way they can impeach
biden impeach kamala harris and he can
crown himself king
they think that's how it works that's
not how it works at all they think
that's how it's really [ __ ]
delusional but that's what they want and
that's what russia wants russia is going
to attempt to do that in the 2022
elections
so keep that in mind also in 2024 but
let's not lose sight of the most
important one
which is 2022 right now the midterms
we have to keep the house the senate but
we also have to clean up these governors
we have to clean up some of these state
legislators we got to get people in
there that actually want to legislate
and help the people of their state not
[ __ ] take away people's liberty by
censoring words that they can say and
preventing them from having medical
procedures that'll save their lives we
have to do that uh joe says here so
russian state tv referred to the flaccid
former guy as our partner trump
i guess russia picks its partners about
as well as it trains its arms
oh joe
oh i guess russia picks its partners
about as well as its trains its army
now
in perfect fashion and style
joe
has no lies to tweet
no lies to tweet thank you joe she's
pointing out the fact
that russia is getting their asses
handed to him by ukraine
which the conflict in ukraine we cannot
we cannot take our eyes off of
and this is the the attempt of russian
state tv to get trump to partner with
them more in their effort to take
ukraine and the democracy in ukraine um
let's see if we can find i want to see
if i can find the uh
uh the cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy
pants
talking about how he wants vladimir
putin to help him because that's that's
that's the quid pro quo here if you
didn't notice uh trump was probably
directed to go on to state uh uh state
media fascist state media here
and let's see let's just search
trump
videos
um
is this it yes this is it aaron's got it
here
um so he goes on he goes on um fascist
state tv real america's voice trader tv
as i call it i think it's a trader cable
news network
you have to i don't know you have to
like
you know give receipts that you were at
january 6 to even get this
this news station you have to be a real
trader to get this news station live
on your
on your roku or wherever
don't i don't [ __ ] know where this is
at real america's voice i'm just glad
there's people out there that watch this
[ __ ] so we don't have to and we get
these clips like this [ __ ] bonehead
here
um
reading off the script that vladimir
putin and the russians have given him
don't
[ __ ] second-guess me when i say that
this guy
was given this to say
he was given this to say he didn't just
pull this out of his fat [ __ ] big mac
eating ass
give me a break this guy couldn't even
come up with a store other than
tiffany's that he could think of of
stores that you go in to shop in
right he couldn't even [ __ ] come up
with walmart
the biggest [ __ ] employer in the
entire country
of which that probably more more of his
constituents spend more money than any
other store in the country walmart he
couldn't come up with that you dumb
[ __ ] you think that this guy
came up with this [ __ ] about russia
and mayors and three million dollars on
his [ __ ] own you think he came up
with that [ __ ] on his own hearken back
to the 2016 election when he did this
before he stood in front of the press
and said russia if you're listening
i hope you find hillary clinton's 30 000
emails or whatever the [ __ ] it was
whatever the [ __ ] stupid ass hillary
clinton email quote was which there was
no [ __ ] emails it's all [ __ ]
oh her emails oh
hunter biden's laptop must have hillary
and hillary clinton's emails on it in a
pizza parlor in a basement somewhere you
stupid [ __ ]
maybe it's maybe it's stored maybe
hunter biden's laptop is stored next to
the space lasers
maybe
this guy did not come up with this on
his own this was a script that was fed
to him by rt by putin by russian tv
so that way they could say he's our
partner that's what happened listen yes
and one thing while i'm on your show as
long as putin now is that's how you know
right there right there in the [ __ ]
beginning
he even says it he even says hey i'm
supposed i'm supposed to come on here
and i'm supposed to say something this
is the thing i'm supposed to say this is
the thing that the reason why i have to
come on your show is to say this thing
because putin wants me to say it
i have to say this for putin
that's what he's saying right there
listen yes and one thing while i'm on
your show one thing while i'm on your
show one thing one thing what
this what he's got the hand thing it's
it's a constant he's playing the what is
it called is it is it the
rump
what's that instrument called where you
put in i don't know
listen
as long as putin now is not exactly a
fan of our country
let him explain where did because chris
wallace wouldn't let me ask the question
why did the mayor of moscow's wife
give the bidens both of them
three and a half million dollars that's
a lot of money
she gave him three and a half million
dollars
so now i would think
putin would know the answer to that i
think he should release it i think we
should know that answer
now you won't get the answer from
ukraine
there's there's a lot to unpack um
almost almost as much as a a big mac and
a large fry but here's the thing
here's the thing
is that this again this is a script that
he was supposed to read on this show
that's why he went on the show that's
why he said what he said that's why he's
capitulating to putin because he was
told to do it
just like he's told to do everything
else that he does
there's nothing that this [ __ ] bonet
does that he isn't told to do
everyone thinks that he's some kind of
3d chess player and somehow he's the con
listen he is a con artist
but there's no one easier to khan than
the con artists themselves he's the
[ __ ] mark
he's the [ __ ] mark they've set him up
hook line sinker here and if you don't
think that he's [ __ ] colluding with
russia and he's not putin's little
[ __ ] puppet after this little scene
here
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
and mj says the tiniest accordion ever
everyone's schooling me here
yes i now know that it's an accordion
thank you crystal
um let's see who else said regina said
it yes it's like an accordion
i think there's a video
of it of him doing that
and speeches and it's like got a cartoon
one whoop whoop whoop
whoop
whoop whoop
i believe
i think so
so you gotta you gotta take this with a
green assault but this is important and
the reason why this is important because
this is a coordinated effort
you don't think it's coordinated come on
it's got to be coordinated right
right
you can't have you can't have
you can't have
donald trump going on
traitor tv here and saying this this
this canned uh statement
where he is he is he has to say it on
their show here listen listen to the
very beginning again
and one thing while i'm on your show
one thing while i'm on your show i have
to say it i was told to say it this is a
statement that was written for me
i must say it i can't go without saying
it here today
on trader tv it was [ __ ] planned it
was planned and then it was planned to
make sure they were [ __ ] saying that
he's their partner and they want him to
be the [ __ ] king of the united states
they want to install him as vladimir
putin's [ __ ] here in the us
that's what they're saying right now our
partner trump we need to get rid of
biden that biden is really hurting us
being hurting us being a dictorial
regime
aunt joe biden and nato boy it really is
being tough on us about us [ __ ]
taking over sovereign nations
of us expanding our fascist state
and murdering innocent women and
children they're really [ __ ] tough on
us
there's no way donald trump would be as
tough on putin as they are in biden so
we want to make sure
that we get rid of biting and put trump
in
put me in coach style [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of here of course this is
coordinated
it's all coordinated he's putin's puppet
kaluti
it does have a sense of collusion
here's more of the grocery store [ __ ]
let's see what other videos we got here
of this
bonehead during this interview
um
uh ron here has this posted he says uh
trump asked his friend putin
let's see what this one is why did the
mayor of moscow's wife oh this is the
same color
the bidens both have them three and a
half million dollars from that's a lot
of money
she gave them three and a half million
dollars
so now i would think
putin would so that's so that is um
that's a um
a clip from like the the at the trailer
of this interview that
that traitor tv put out before they
played it um but ron here is pointing
out trump asked friend putin to take a
break from murders and innocent
civilians to help him frame biden that's
the other craziest part about this
is that everyone thinks
after this video that oh my god that
must exist
and and the thing is is that putin's
gonna help him well putin ain't gonna
[ __ ] help this [ __ ]
he's got a war to worry about he just he
just wants putin just wants americans to
doubt democracy that's it his enemy is
democracy he wants you to doubt it we
are 50 54 minutes into the second hour
we're almost finished up here on
wednesday holy [ __ ] that was fast i
thought it was fast did you guys think
it was fast that was really fast two
hours boom boom boom we didn't even have
gabe on
he never popped in he must have got busy
i think he's over there editing videos
no i'm dead serious i think he's got
some videos that are going to come out
this week i think that's what he's doing
so it's just me for the entire two hours
today non-stop uh we took a we took a
break here there
but non-stop two hours every single
weekday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific right here on youtube twitter
twitch and now on the midas touch
facebook page
we are on all the socials
i
i i think i don't know uh if anyone's
got tic tac out there i think there's a
way to stream to tick tock
if someone knows that way
dm me because i i think there's a way to
actually dm to dick doc
i'm not sure though it says i can i
don't know how you do it um i think i
can do it i don't know how but i think
yeah you can you can do that so we might
we might i don't know we might go live
on dick dock why not i'll probably get
banned from there though
tic tocs are a real [ __ ] on their lives
i used to do them all the time on tick
tock the lives but yeah they're they
they
they don't have much of a reporting
system over there
it's really wild they'll ban you for
almost nothing and then they won't ban
the people they should ban
so
remember subscribe to the youtube
channel
because we have all the great the great
uh interviews that we repost you can go
re-watch the shows if you miss them you
can also download it every single show
every single weekday
after the show on all the directories
apple spotify the the most the most
famous boycotted
directory there is spotify
everyone loves the boycott spotify and
go over to like anchor who and spotify
owns go over to this platform which
spotify owns that play listen
let me tell you a secret about the
directories while you're over there
downloading our episode and giving us a
five star review know that no matter
what directory on
if you're not on google or apple it's
probably owned by spotify
i'm just i'm just letting you you guys
know of your boycott and spotify that if
you're not on google or apple
downloading our episode and giving us a
five star review because that's what you
should be doing
that's what you should be doing right
after the show now not right after cause
it takes me a little bit to download it
upload the audio
into the directories and then it it get
to where you can download it it takes a
little bit this is live
but once it is uploaded you know here in
a couple hours
know that when you're downloading our
episode from today and yesterday's
episode you don't want to miss
yesterday's you don't want to miss that
one go get that one and mondays go
download that one too you want to listen
to that one
go listen to those two episodes very
important we talk about will smith and
chris rock
getting slapped in the face by will
smith so don't miss out on monday
go download those episodes but while
you're there on that directory
downloading your episodes if you're not
on apple if you're not on google
know
that it is probably spotify that owns
that directory
if you're boycotting spotify i'm just
pointing that out just pointing that out
just pointing that out
57 minutes into the hour
i really appreciate you guys all the new
listeners um you really you guys have
been fantastic over on facebook you guys
are really participating in the chat
um karen says she'll be here tomorrow
loved it uh karen must be a new listener
so everyone out there that is a new
listener just know you can find us on
facebook now on the midas such facebook
page uh you can find us on youtube uh
twitter twitch just go to
thetonymichaels.com
you can go to the link in my bio on on
any of the social media and go to
thetonymichaels.com
and you can find all those links to all
the channels all the stations
all the places where you can download
upload watch listen i mean if you don't
like to watch me and talk you know watch
my beautiful face which i don't know why
you wouldn't but if you just want to
hear my beautiful voice we're on all the
directories just type in the tony
michaels podcast
google the tony michaels podcast
go to youtube type in the tony michaels
podcast subscribe
like follow us there
super important you don't want to miss
anything
and if you do it's okay it's okay if you
miss some things
because then you can just re-watch it
also i don't know if you guys know this
but i'm on instagram now i've been
posting some stuff overnight i'm trying
to figure out how the grammy gram works
trying to figure out how the grams work
over there on instagram
um i'm starting to get it starting to
figure out how the video and the posting
works go follow me on instagram if
you're on instagram and you can follow
me on facebook too just type in the tony
michaels and you'll find my page i've
got a page
and i don't post a lot on the facebook
page but i do kinda
because if you guys know if you post on
instagram
instagram and facebook are part of the
meta thing the whole meta [ __ ]
the zuckerberg meta thing so you can
so when you post when you post on
instagram you can post it on facebook
too so if you you're just on facebook
you can find all my posts over there as
well just go follow me on facebook the
tony michaels just search it i think it
pops up it should pop up
it should pop up the tony michaels go to
thetonymichaels.com
follow us everywhere you've been
listening to the tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking